مجلس النواب من دون القياده النسخه
الامريكيه من المراه الحديديه نانسي
بيلوسي لن تكون زعيمه الديمقراطيين من
الانفصاعدا التنحي عن المنصب الذي شغلته
لنحو عقدين كان متوقعا خاصه مع حصول
الجمهوريين على الاغلبيه في المجلس
والهجوم الذي تعرض له زوجها قبل اسابيع
خليفه
سيتم التصويت عليه في الاجتماع العام
لاعضاء مجلس النواب الديمقراطي في
الثلاثين من نوفمبر واول المرشحين حكيم
الذي اعلن ترشحه قبل ساعات وبحال فوزه
سيدخل التاريخ ايضا كونه اول صاحب بشره
سمراء يقود الحزبه الديمقراطي في مجلس
النواب
الخليفه الطبيعيه
عمري
صغيرا كبيرا بين الاجيال عن الثلاثي
الحالي من القاده الديمقراطيين بمجلس سيد
النواب الذين يكبرونه بثلاثه عقود فهو حصل
على تاييد الزعيم
الاغلبيهما
[تصفيق]
اثناء عمله بالكونغرس فان ذلك لا يؤثر على
قدرته الكبيره لقياده الديمقراطيين في
مجلس النواب او حتى العمل مع الاداره نحن
نعلم
قياده مهمه
الاغلبيه في الانتخابات المقبله
فودافون
باعتبارها احد اقوى الشخصيات في الحزب
الديمقراطي واكثرها استقطابا في السياسه
الامريكيه
ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن